εγώ είμαι εδώ για να εξυπηρετήσω των πελάτι είναι εγώ που πρέπει να μετακινηθώ από
τι θέση μου για να φτάσω εκεί που θέλει οπελά της να εμαι αυτό είναι
κουρτούρα η οποία υπάρχει σε λίγες εταιρές ακόμε και στον ιδιωρικώ τομεα και είναι αντίθε
τη κουρτορα που υπάρχει στο περισσότερο δημόσιο αυτό προσπαθούμε να αλλάξουμε να γίνουμε παράδειγμα μιας
διαφορετικής κουρτούρας στο δημόσιο που ελπίζουμε να τοέχουν ανάγκη και οι πολίτες θεωρώ είναιαπαραίτητη για
τους πολίτες ώστε να γίνεται ει και ευκολότερη καθυμειώνα του πολίτ η αλήθεια είναι ότι
ταν επιδπιδήσει στο δημόσιον έχεις πολλές μονο πολί ακές καταστάσεις όπου δεν έχει άλλος που
κάνει αυτό που κάνεις εσύ οπότε κίν τη ρόνα πουχιστών πολίτη να πεναντισού μπορεί να
πέσει στην παγίδα να θεωρήσεις ότι ι αφού δεν έχει άλτη ν επιλογή κοντάμου που
έναεδώ θα αρθεί δεν θα το κάνω τώρα θα το κάνω αύριο θα το κάνω
μεθαύριο είν μπορεί να μην το κανόσον καλά θα πρέπε να το κάνω και πάλι
είναι οκα καθυστερεις εμός αυτή προφανός πο να δημουργήσει πρόβλημα στων πολίτη που το ζητραστείο
και κόστωση για τη χώρα μένουμε μπίσω σα χώρα γιατί έχουμε ακόμα δημόσιον το οποίον
δεν είναι τόσο πελάτ ο κεντρικόν η πολιτό κεντρικόν πάμε στον πολί τη όσο α
πρέπε να είναι η σύδα δεν είναι τυχεαφυσικά που έχει αλλάξει δι ότι και ησίτα
κάποτε ήταν μονοπολιώ και ησίτα κάποτε δεν ήταν τόσο πελάτο κεντρική αυτή τη στιγμή έχουμε
να αλλάξει γιατί είμαστε σε ανταγωνισμό αυτό θα σας βοήθησι ο ανταγωνισμό θεώρητα κατον της
εγατο αν δεν αλλάξεις δεν επιβιώνει στον ανταγωνισμόοπότε επιδεί εμείς έπρεπε να αλλάξουμε έχει κοση
χρόνια που είναι στον ανταγωνισμόνισίτα οπότε σίγουρα τα πρώτα χρόνια ήταν δύσκολα και δεν αλλάξαμε